>> Laura: TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
IS THAT REALLY FOLLIES?
>> THE FOLLIES LOOKS A LITTLE
BEATEN UP.
A LITTLE BEATEN UP.
>> Laura: THAT'S OKAY.
SAMANTHA BEE'S APOLOGY TO IVANKA
TRUMP SEEMS FAKE.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID, "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" BEST SELLING AUTHOR,
RAYMOND IS GOING TO TELL US,
RAYMOND, THIS WAS A TELEVISION
AWARDS CEREMONY.
WHAT GREAT TIMING.
>> THIS IS FROM THE TELEVISION
ACADEMY, THAT GRANTS THE EMMYS.
THEY GAVE SAMANTHA A SPECIAL
AWARD, SAMANTHA BEE, FOR HER
SOCIAL ACTIVISM.
THIS IS A WOMAN WHO TOLD IVANKA
TRUMP, YOU'RE A FECKLESS "C"
WORD AND YOU SHOULD WEAR
SOMETHING TIGHT AND LOW-CUT SO
YOUR FATHER WILL CHANGE YOUR
IMMIGRATION POLICIES.
SHE HAD TO APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
BUT THE CEREMONY IN WHICH THE
MEDIA WASN'T ALLOWED INTO, WE
DON'T HAVE THE AUDIO, BUT WE
HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID.
WE SPENT THE DAY WRESLING WITH
THE REPERCUSSIONS OF ONE BAD
WORD WHEN WE SHOULD HAVE ALL
SPENT THE DAY AS A NATION THAT
WE ARE WRENCHING CHILDREN FROM
THEIR PARENTS.
NOW, IT WASN'T ONE WORD, IT WAS
ALSO THE CONTEXT THAT SOMEHOW
IVANKA TRUMP SHOULD TART UP TO
GET HER FATHER'S ATTENTION.
THAT WAS NEVER ADDRESSED AT ALL
EITHER IN THE APOLOGY OR HERE.
>> Laura: THE FACT THAT IVANKA
TRUMP WAS HOLDING UP HER INFANT
SON, LIKE THAT WAS AN AFFRONT TO
SAMANTHA BEE.
SHE'S TRASHED ME -- LET ME HOLD
IT UP.
IT ACTUALLY WORKS AGAINST
VAMPIRES, SAMANTHA.
SHE'S TRASHED ME FOR THAT.
ACTUAL LIP
ACTUAL LI
ACTUALLY, DO WE WANT TO PLAY THE
CLIP?
THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
WE DON'T WANT TO GIVE IT THE
LIGHT OF DAY.
SO SHE CONTINUES TO BE PRESENT,
CLAIMING SHE'S SORRY, MOVE IT TO
THE POLITICAL CONVERSATION.
WHO DIED AND MADE HER HEAD OF
AMNESTY INTERNATIONAL?
>> HERE SHE IS, CALLING A WOMAN,
REDUCING A WOMAN TO GENITAL YEAH
WITH THIS HORRIBLE WORD.
NOW THE PRESIDENT STARTED
TWEETING.
NATURALLY, HIS DAUGHTER WAS
ATTACKED HERE.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
WHY AREN'T THEY FIRING NO-TALENT
SAMANTHA BEE FOR THE LOW-RATING
SKILL.
A TOTAL DOUBLE STANDARD.
THAT'S OKAY.
WE'RE WINNING.
AND WE'LL BE DOING SO FOR A LONG
TIME.
>> Laura: I LIKE HOW WINNING IS
CAPITALIZED.
NOT CLEAR WHY, BUT I'LL LIKE IT.
>> BRIAN JUMPED INTO THIS AND
SAID THE PRESIDENT HAS GONE TOO
FAR.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IT SEEMS, BRIAN, LIKE THE
PRESIDENT'S FOLLOWING A LOT OF
CONSERVATIVE PUNDITS JUMPING ON
THE DOUBLE STANDARD BANDWAGON.
>> SOMETHING WE HEAR ALMOST
EVERY DAY ON THE PRESIDENT'S
FAVORITE FOX NEWS TOX SHOWS,
TAPPING INTO THE VICTIMHOOD,
CONSERVATIVES ARE TREATED IN THE
WORST WAY THAN LIBERALS.
IN THIS CASE ROSEANNE BARR
TREATED WORSE THAN SAMANTHA BEE.
>> THEY'RE MAKING IT SOUND LIKE
THE PRESIDENT IS BLAMED FOR THE
FOUL-MOUTHED COMEDIENNES.
THEY EXISTED BEFORE TRUMP,
THEY'LL EXIST AFTER TRUMP.
SAMANTHA BEE'S RATINGS ARE DOWN
BY ALMOST HALF.
>> Laura: HE'S WINNING ON
ECONOMY, ON TRADE, FOCUS ON THE
SUBSTANCE, WHO CARES WHAT --
>> BUT CAN HE MATCH OBAMA'S "THE
FINAL YEAR" THE HBO DOCUMENTARY,
LIKE AN EXTENDED WEST
WING PORTRAYED THE NATIONAL
SECURITY AN
SECURITY APP
SECURITY APPAR
SECURITY APPARAT
SECURITY APPARATUS
SECURITY APPARATUS.
HERE'S A LITTLE CLIP OF THAT
DOCUMENTARY.
>> WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE IT
WILL BE HARDER TO DISMANTLE IN
THE EVENT WE TAKE A DIFFERENT
TURN.
>> I JUST CAME OUTSIDE TO TRY TO
PROCESS ALL THIS.
I CAN'T PUT IT INTO WORDS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE WORDS ARE.
>> BEN RHODES CAN'T FIND THE
WORD.
THEY ALL THOUGHT HILLARY WAS
GOING TO WIN.
THE "BOSTON GLOBE" WROTE THIS
TEAM'S PRAGMATIC IDEALISM ARE
ENOUGH TO MAKE YOU WEEP WITH ALL
THAT HAS GONE MISSING.
>> Laura: SAMANTHA POWERS WAS
UNMASKING INDIVIDUALS EVERY DAY,
SOMEHOW OVER AT THE U.N.
SHE SAID, WE HAVE TO MAKE IT
FOREIGN POLICY APPARATUS, IRAN
DEAL'S GONE, WHAT ELSE?
>> CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> >> Laura: GONE.
>> AND CUBA.
THOSE ARE THE THREE BENCHMARK
THINGS THEY CELEBRATE IN THE
DOCUMENTARY, ON A DAY WHEN
DONALD TRUMP HAS BROUGHT NORTH
KOREA TO THE WHITE HOUSE, THIS
IS A HARD DOCUMENTARY TO
SWALLOW.
HOW TIME HAS DEVOURED WHAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE ULTIMATE
NARRATIVE.
>> Laura: I WOULD HAVE BEEN
LOVING TO SIT NEXT TO BEN RHODES